non eh bien allez ola olé
[Applaudissements]
line renaud mon jour
je connais ma mère
ma mère est une grande fan de l'émission
mais elle regarde toutes les semaines
elle me dit mon fils était beaucoup trop
grossier ouais donc la semaine prochaine
je viens pour te surveiller parce que tu
donne une mauvaise image de la famille
ouais
écouteurs tous les cas une chose est
certaine c'est que à la veille de la
fête des mères je suis très heureux de
vous recevoir parce que vous symbolisez
un peu toutes les mamans
votre fils à une telle réputation que
lorsqu'une jeune femme bien dans
l'émission elle vient auparavant
mais en plus de puiser une once à rien
il serait capable de relever votre jus
alors oui
as tu verras comme un mur et là je suis
très différents un
oui mais
je crois que l'année prochaine je les
perds toutes les émissions
mais voilà c'est formidable et pénales
ta mère oui sauf que dans ce qu'on
appelle une vieille [ __ ]
c'est la fête des mères on peut alors on
se calme et petits connards
mon excuse moi cslt première partie
[Applaudissements]
ça va
non pas
la peur est la peur est terrorisée
détends-toi chérubins enlève ta main
je ne mange pas de ce pain là maman
normale ça s'appelait
way qu'est ce que tu préfères à la télé
à part les émissions de langue allemande
a pas raté édition à toi y'a que ça que
tu dis la vérité moment qu'est ce que tu
regardes tous les jours
1 il ya un piège là
non c'est une affiche à gifles
[Applaudissements]
ou lui mais c'est bien plus belle la vie
ça va non mais tend sa main et moi je me
mets devant je bosse animé par toi blard
par toi de là elle a droit de regarder
ce qu'elle veut c'est un jugement serait
bien c'est une merde faut dire ce qui
est bon dans ces matches c'est
la première fois que tu as tu connu
madame elle veut quelque chose raconte
et raconte c'est pourquoi non merde aux
toits mais ce monde alors on a long way
et toute idée
l'histoire et wade je les aurai en fait
il est entré dans vingt ans après il
élit son île rebelle il avait invité sa
maman est là certes c'est vraiment un il
rentre dans ma loge il fait les deux
buts que j'avais promis
comment tu l'as fait celui-là mais c'est
impossible c'était pas tout seul oui et
pour être sûr de ne rien rater de nos
latitudes abonnez vous il m'était
impossible eux